the horrendous non-call at the end of
the nfc championship game has created
all sorts of avenues unrelated to what
we typically hear about when there is a
controversial finish to an nfl game
there's been litigation already filed in
new orleans seeking to force
commissioner roger goodell to order a
do-over of the final minute and 49
seconds of that contest and even though
that's not something that should be
taken seriously here's something that
maybe should be taken seriously a member
of congress u.s representative cedric
richmond from new orleans wants to bring
goodell before the house judiciary and a
trust subcommittee to testify about that
non-call and surely about other things
and even if it doesn't happen now
because obviously there's plenty of
other things going on in washington that
would make this a low priority
as legalized gambling spreads throughout
the country there will eventually be an
outcome that forces the nfl to come in
and explain why it doesn't do more
to improve officiating and when we look
at the nfl's reaction to what's happened
in the aftermath of the nfc championship
game that that resistance to making
significant changes you have to wonder
at some point will congress say hey nfl
that's not good enough you may think
it's good enough we don't think it's
good enough because too much money is
changing hands based upon the outcomes
of these games so they need to be
unaffected by the human error that comes
from officiating error so that is where
the nfl needs to be concerned that is
why the nfl needs to take this seriously
even if it doesn't happen now if the nfl
doesn't improve its officiating it will
happen at some point down the road
either when the outcome of a game is
affected or more importantly when
millions of dollars change hand because
a team doesn't cover the spread due to
an officiating mistake that is going to
be part of the future of the nfl overall
it's good that legalized gambling is
spreading because the nfl is going to
make a lot more money but they better
spend money on making officiating better
or they're going to have to deal with
congress and other governmental entities
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports